parler de cet acte 67 dg les jeunes nous
sommes avec michel fize sociologue et
directeur de recherche au cnrs bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation il ya donc cette séquence
qu'on verra tout à l'heure jérôme
rodriguez interpellé de façon musclée
par les forces de l'ordre avant que le
cortège ne s'élance place de la
république depuis la place de la
république à lille était en train de
déjeuner avec d'autres manifestants et
puis ce matin à paris cette autre figure
du mouvement des jeunes eric drew et qui
s'est rendu au salon de l'agriculture
alors que le chef de l'état emmanuel
macron on parcourait les allées de la
porte de versailles et eric deroo et qui
a été expulsé manu militari alors qu'il
tentait de se rapprocher de se
rapprocher du cordon présidentielle
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
aujourd'hui csn ça m'inspire d'abord que
j'avais le sentiment qu'on avait une
pratique retenue de la garde à vue que
ça devait être évidemment une procédure
mais à n'utiliser que dans des cas
véritablement s'imposant bon là je
trouve qu'effectivement chaque
interpellation qu'il y ait dans la dans
la foulée une garde à vue ça me paraît
un peu un peu excessif parce que je le
précise eric gruer a été donc arrêté et
placé en garde à vue pour réveiller tout
à fait tout à fait voilà alors moi je
pense encore une fois qu'on peut pas
résoudre
on peut pas résoudre un conflit par
cette espèce de deux principes temps
d'interpellation et d'arrestations et de
placement en garde à vue six thématiques
vont il ya des problèmes qui sont mis
sur la table
il faudra bien un jour les résoudre
parce qu'encore une fois malgré plus
d'un an et demi de gilet jaune avec un
mouvement social qui a suivi bah les
grands problèmes demeurent alors c'est
peut-être une solution parce que ce
matin emmanuel macron a été vivement
interpellé par une manifestante à qui il
a proposé d'arrêter de manifester il a
aussi promis à cette occasion il a
promis de recevoir un groupe de gilet
jaune
ce serait alors la première fois est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à un entretien à
l'elysée dans les prochains jours les
prochaines semaines mais je crois encore
une fois
qu'il n'y a pas une défaillance totale
de discussion ça fait deux ans qu'on
discute avec les syndicats en
particulier mais pour aboutir finalement
à une perspective qui apparaît
maintenant hautement probable le 49-3 à
l'assemblée nationale donc on a un peu
le sentiment que malgré un an et demi de
de gilet jaune malgré les cheminots les
infirmières les avocats malgré les
agriculteurs dont on ne dira jamais
assez la situation dramatique dans
laquelle ils se trouvent parce que je
rappelle quand même au passage qu' il y
a eu l'année dernière plus de 600
agriculteurs qui se sont donnés la mort
aussi bien d'ailleurs et chef
d'exploitation des salariés un à deux
suicides
je crois même qu'on doit être plutôt
plus près de deux suicides par jour
voilà alors donc je crois encore une
fois que l'exercice de communication
c'est bien mais les problèmes restent
reste pendant là ce serait une première
c'est effectivement été reçu à l'elysée
un groupe de gilet jaune alors emmanuel
macron a précisé je vais le site et
lorsqu'il s'est adressé donc à cette
manifestante ce matin porte de
versailles vous me structurer un gros
que je vous reçois et je vous reçois
sans problème moi je suis pour le
dialogue
on se prend une heure et on discute
c'est la communication forcé de réagir à
brûle pourpoint sa cette manifestante
qui qui l'interpellait à nouveau
vivement encore une fois il n'ya pas une
panne totale de discussion dans ce pays
il ya une panne de décisions concertées
de décisions co élaborés moi j'ai envie
de dire finalement en regardant cette
présidence d' emmanuel macron qu'elle
ressemble incontestablement à une
dictature constitutionnelle
pourquoi parce qu'en fin de compte voilà
un chef d'état qui a entre les mains
tous les pouvoirs et qui va finalement
aboutir à son projet formulé il ya deux
ans c'est à dire le projet de retraite
non seulement il va être adopté par le
49-3 ou pas mais probablement par le
49-3 pour respecter les délais qui ont
été convenues mais il va être adopté
dans les formes initiales
c'est à dire tel que edouard philippe
l'a présenté il ya encore il ya encore
quelques quelques mois donc c'est vrai
qu'on peut avoir le sentiment tout
à part ça tout ça pour en arriver là
tout ça pour arriver finalement à une
procédure qui était connue d'avancé
voilà c'est là où l'on voit que le
rapport des forces est complètement tu
es complètement déséquilibré et qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on invente une une
démocratie pour tous ou là une
démocratie du partage notamment des voix
des uns et des autres la structuration
du mouvement des jets les jeunes c'est
ce que met en avant emmanuel macron dans
cette optique de probables entretien à
l'elysée avec un groupe de gilet jaune
on en a beaucoup parlé de la
structuration des gilet jaune est ce
qu'il vous faut restructurer le
mouvement aujourd'hui
mais il ne l'est pas parce que la
philosophie de ce mouvement n'est pas la
structuration 1 je rappelle que c'est
l'égalité totale de ses membres qui est
qui et sur le devant de la scène
bon ok on peut parler des rides drouet
maxime nicole pour en prendre un autre
bon ils ne sont pas les leaders du
mouvement des gilets jaunes parce
qu'encore une fois le propre le propre
d'un tel mouvement
c'est d'avoir une co élaboration des
décisions voilà par une parole une
parole circulantes sans qu'il y ait de
chef de file savez c'est si la grande
tradition de nuit debout en 2016 c'était
déjà ça également donc qu'aujourd'hui on
appelle à la structuration qu'on en
fasse presque une condition
effectivement de la rencontre ça peut
paraître une violation de la philosophie
de ce mouvement des gilets jaunes
alors voilà ces images
en provenance de l'île où se déroule la
mobilisation nationale de l'acte 67 des
gilet jaune lille cette semaine la
semaine dernière c'était rennes le
mouvement se délocalise de plus en plus
régulièrement en région - 2 - d'aussi
dans les manifestations c'est un fait
comment est ce que vous vous envisager
l'avenir des jeunes là je pense que si
j'étais un gilet jaune
je serai comme dans l'inquiétude parce
qu'il semble que l'exécutif le pouvoir
s'adapte maintenant à ce genre de à ce
genre de situation voilà et qu'elle ne
suffit pas à briser le rapport de force
un joli et récemment le compte rendu du
mouvement contre la réforme des
retraites en 2010 en 2010 il y avait
encore entre 1 et 2 millions de
manifestants dans la rue c'est vrai que
le nombre un jeu je crains qu'il ne
qu'il ne fasse la différence d'un mot je
rappelle que vous avez rédigé en lire
sur ce mouvement social intitulé une
insurrection populaire au destin
incertain
comment ont évolué les revendications
des gilet jaune ces derniers mois depuis
le début des mouvements
je pense qu'il ya une ne vienne il ya
une revendication phare que l'on voit
encore c'est le rique référendum
d'initiative citoyenne parce qu'il est
vraiment l'outil principal d'une autre
démocratie
est-ce que la revendication n'accompagne
pas aussi aujourd'hui les autres
mobilisations nationales plus
généralement je crois que les autres
mobilisations ne sont quand même axé
davantage sur la question du pouvoir
d'achat la question des carrières la
question des moyens matériels et humains
qui font défaut ce soit chez les
enseignants chez le personnel soignant
au voir chez les policiers eux mêmes
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation michel fize sociologue
directeur de recherches au cnrs